margarina não é amiga do seu coração
fuja desse marketing da indústria
composta por conservantes estabilizantes
gorduras artificialmente criadas a
partir de óleo vegetal modificado a
margarina é o resultado de um complexo
processo Industrial antigamente a
hidrogenação era usada para solidificar
o óleo vegetal criando a textura cremosa
que conhecemos mas isso gerava gorduras
trans altamente inflamatórias e
comprovadamente prejudiciais à saúde
hoje a técnica foi substituída pela
Inter esterificação que não produz
gordura trans porém ainda deixa resíduos
químicos perigosos e repletos de
radicais livres que causam sim danos às
células a margarina pode desregular o
colesterol e Estudos em animais indicam
que pode afetar o cérebro estimular o
desenvolvimento de diabetes e causar
problemas hepáticos e
cardiovasculares